on sunday president trump golfed
but before hitting the links for the
second day in a row trump ignited a
short-lived media frenzy
when he seemed to finally admit defeat
tweeting about president-elect joe biden
he won because the election was rigged
but soon that tweet came down and trump
sent out a new one
saying i concede nothing trump's false
claims of voting fraud have been refuted
by state and federal officials
as biden attended church services near
his home in delaware
trump's own former national security
adviser
indicated trump is sabotaging the
transfer of power
pretty soon we'll get the stab in the
back theories
we'll get the dark conspiracy theories
continued
and he will make life as difficult as he
can for the incoming biden
administration i think that
harms the country with covet 19 cases
and
deaths sharply on the rise across the
u.s
biden's designated chief of staff said
the transition
must be seamless there are people at hhs
making plans to implement that vaccine
our experts need to talk to those people
as soon as possible
so nothing drops in this change of power
we're going to have on january 20th
several states have imposed severe new
restrictions
to curb the virus in recent days a
co-chairperson of biden's coveted task
force said
biden would not order a total lockdown
when he takes office
the better way to think about these
safety restrictions is more as a dial
that we turn
up and down depending on severity
congress will be back in session on
monday with millions of americans out of
jobs and plunged into poverty by the
pandemic
democrats called on republican senate
leader mitch mcconnell to speed up work
on a coveted relief and recovery bill
the bottom line is very simple we need
a large strong coveted bill to deal
with our problems we have heard for
months
every time we get close to a deal
senator mcconnell
says no he has become the doctor no
of covid a transition on hold
as the virus gains the upper hand rob
reynolds
al jazeera